Derivative of a function measures its ‘RATE of change’.
Imagine a quantity denoted by variable ‘Y’
which is continuously changing.
But how it changes is CONTROLLED by another
quantity, denoted by variable ‘X’.
We can say that the variable ‘Y’ called
the dependent variable is a FUNCTION of the
variable ‘X’ called the independent variable.
The function ‘F’ tells us how the value
of ‘Y’ changes with the value of ‘X’.
The derivative of a function at a particular
value of ‘X’, tells us the RATE of change
of ‘Y’ with respect to ‘X’, at that particular value of ’X’.
That is how fast or slow the value of ‘Y’
changes with respect to ‘X’.
In our previous video, we saw how to find
the derivative of a function.
The whole process is summarised like this.
It is called Differentiation.
This ratio here is called the average rate
of change between two values of ‘X’ which
are ‘X not’ and ‘X not plus delta X’.
If ‘delta X’ is greater than Zero, then
‘X not plus delta X’ will be somewhere
here on the ‘X axis’.
Then this ratio is the slope of this secant
line between these two points.
Now as we find the average rate in the interval
closer and closer to ‘X not’, we see that
these secant lines approach the tangent line at ‘X not’.
This would be true even if we take ‘Delta
X’ to be less than zero.
Then ‘X not plus delta X’ will be somewhere
here on the ‘X axis’.
And as we find the average rate in the interval
closer and closer to ‘X not’, we see that
these secant lines approach the tangent line at ‘X not’.
So we say that in the limit delta X tends
to Zero the average rate of change APPROACHES
the instantaneous rate of change at X not.
That is nothing but the derivative of the
function at X not.
We denote it by putting a dash like this on
the notation for the function.
Note that the limit delta X tends to zero
does not mean we put ‘Delta X’ equal to
zero in this ratio.
This would result in the ratio being equal
to ‘zero divided by zero’ which does not
make any sense.
In this video, we will understand what this
really means.
Along with it we will also explore different
theoretical aspects of the derivative of a
function.
Consider this simple example.
‘Y’ is equal to square of ‘X’.
Let’s say we want to find the derivative
of this function at a particular value of
‘X’, say ‘X one’.
Can you find this out?
Actually, in one of our previous videos, we
found the answer to this.
We had found the instantaneous speed of an
object for such a relationship between the
distance travelled and the time elapsed.
And to find the derivative we would first
find the average rate of change.
That is, how the value of function changes
as the value of ‘X’ changes by ‘delta
X’.
‘F of X one plus delta X’ and ‘F of
X one’ will be equal to this.
After expanding this term and simplifying,
we will get this.
And after dividing by ‘delta X’ we will
get this final expression.
Now we know that to get the derivative, we
will need to consider the interval ‘delta
X’ tending to zero.
So we put delta X equal to Zero here and get this.
It is the derivative of the function at X one.
But now notice that all these expressions
are equivalent to each other.
So what if instead of putting ‘delta X equal
to Zero’ here, we put ‘delta X equal to
Zero here or here?
We see that we will get the numerator and
the denominator both equal to zero.
But for this final expression, we got the
answer as two times X one.
So what is going on here?
Why can we substitute ‘delta X equal to
zero’ here and not here?
Actually, substituting ‘Delta X’ equal
to zero at any step here is not correct.
Notice that in these steps we are dividing
by delta X.
And we know we can’t divide by ‘Zero’.
What ‘delta X’ tends to zero means is
that we are considering smaller and smaller
values of ‘Delta X’.
The values of ‘Delta X’ are close to Zero,
but NEVER zero.
But among all these steps here, delta X does
not explicitly occur in the denominator here.
So It is easy to see from this step that as
delta X gets smaller and smaller, the average
rate gets closer and closer to ‘2 times X one’.
So substituting ‘Delta X’ equal zero here
is just CONVENIENT to reach this conclusion.
But always be aware of what it really means
to put ‘Delta X’ equal to zero here.
Now notice one more thing.
Although we had not explicitly stated it,
here we took delta X to be greater than zero.
That is, we are finding the average rate between
X one and values of 'X' greater than it.
But it is necessary to consider the case when
delta X is less than zero.
That is, finding the average rate between
X one and values of 'X' lesser than it.
As we find the average rate when delta X tends
to zero, this average rate should approach
‘two times X one’.
So let’s find the average rate in this case
when delta X is less than zero.
We can see the calculation for finding the
average rate of change will be the same as
this.
But in the first case, this average rate will
always be greater than 'two times X one'.
And in the second case this average rate will
always be less than 'two times X one'.
Now when delta X tends to zero, both these
average rates will approach the same limit
‘two times X one’.
Now we can conclude that the derivative of
this function at X one is equal 'two times
X one'.
So we see that to find the derivative of a
function at a particular value of ‘X’,
we have to find the average rate for two cases:
When ‘delta X’ is greater than zero and
when ‘delta X’ is less than zero.
Now when delta x tends to zero, if both these
average rates approach the same number, then
that number is the derivative of the function
at that particular value of ‘x’.
But consider this function now.
It is called the absolute value or modulus function.
These vertical bars say that the value of
‘Y’ is equal to only the non negative
value of X.
That is if ‘X’ is greater than or equal
to zero, then ‘Y’ is equal to ‘X’.
And if ‘X’ is less than zero then ‘Y’
is equal to ‘negative of X’.
Can you find the derivative of this function
at ‘X’ equal to zero?
Share your thoughts in the comments section below.
We will find its derivative in the next lesson.
Don’t forget to subscribe in order to get notified.